bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation d'avoir quelle est la
situation dans la capitale libanaise
actuellement depuis la fin du week end
manifestations continuent mais avec un
rythme un peu plus calme il n'y a pas eu
d'affrontement hier soir lundi mais tout
le monde est en train d'attendre la
formation d'un nouveau gouvernement et
et tout le monde est de plus en plus
convaincus que la classe politique
dirigeante n'écoute rien n'entend rien
ne réalisent pas que depuis trois mois
les libanais sont dans la rue pour
demander la fin d'un d'une façon de
faire de la politique basée sur des
tractations politiciennes
afin de garantir des lieux de pouvoirs
essentiels à la corruption de la classe
politique
la formation de ce nouveau gouvernement
suit exactement le même chemin que les
anciens gouvernements cela naturellement
nous pousse à prévoir de nouveau un
regain de tension est encore plus de
manifestations surtout lors du week-end
prochain
trois mois de contestation maintenant
qu'est ce qui a mis le feu aux poudres a
le feu couvait sous les cendres
c'était un feu nourri par la corruption
d'une classe politique qui qui n'a aucun
scrupule à augmenter les dépenses
publiques sans aucun revenu sans aucune
réforme à s'endetter davantage à pousser
la banque centrale à prêter de l'argent
à l'état en prenant les réserves que les
libanais ont mis dans les banques
privées
celle ci est envoyé à la banque centrale
et de la banque centrale prêter à l'état
l'état se retrouve dans l'incapacité de
payer et les banques sont dans
l'incapacité de nous donner notre argent
en même temps ce gouvernement confronté
à des crises économiques énormes à des
crises financières énormes ce a cru bon
en octobre 2019 de taxer l'utilisation
de l'application whatsapp pour faire des
pour les appels voix tient ce qui était
complètement ridicule dans un pays aussi
endetté et en même temps où la
corruption est clair et où les fortunes
sont concentrés entre les mains de 1% de
la population de taxer tout le monde de
manière aussi inique
c'était
ce qui a poussé les gens dans la rue
mais aujourd'hui on manifeste surtout
contre une classe politique tout d'abord
corrompu mais clairement incompétente et
ce à son comportement durant ces trois
derniers mois prouvent son incompétence
la capitale libanaise a connu ce week
end à un des pensions très importante un
week end de violences sans précédent on
voit que le mouvement finalement il
s'est radicalisé on compte au moins cinq
cent quarante six blessés est ce que
vous vous dénoncez une répression
je dénonce tout d'abord l'inaction de la
classe politique et sa déconnexion
totale avec la réalité
c'est un mouvement qui depuis 90 jours
était un mouvement pacifique
face à cela on voit une classe politique
qui se chamaillent vraiment un
comportement ridicule face à la crise
qui se chamaillent sur des postes
ministériels alors que le liban doit
rembourser une grande partie de sa dette
le mois prochain et en mars qu'il est
dans l'incapacité de payer les prix
augmentent à un rythme incroyable
les banques humilie les libanais qui
vont retirer leur propre argent des
banques en les empêchant de l'avoir
accès à leur propre argent et en face de
cela on voit une classe politique qui se
chamaillent sur le nombre de député
druze grec catholique maronite pour ce
parti ou pour l'autre est théoriquement
ce sont tous des partis alliés
donc quand on voit une classe politique
tellement déconnectés des réalités
ça ajoute un degré d'un su d'humiliation
ce qui rend compréhensible les actions
violentes que nous conte que le
condamnons que le comptable non pas ce
n'est pas vraiment la question mais ce
qui est vraiment insultant c'est face à
une crise pareille voir une classe
politique qui se comportent comme si de
rien n'était malheureusement la
radicalisation devient devient juste
sinon justifier elle devient naturelle
et est ce que le gouvernement a les
cartes en main pour stopper cette cette
flambée de violence au liban
actuellement la solution n'est que
politique
la solution ne viendra que d'un
gouvernement qui inspire confiance à
plusieurs milieux le prochain
on doit respirer confiance à la rue aux
citoyens qui n'en peuvent plus de cette
façon de faire de la politique qui nous
a conduit à la banqueroute
mais le gouvernement doit également
inspirer confiance à la communauté
internationale dans toutes ces
différences afin de pouvoir compter sur
eux un jour pour un soutien à la
rétablissement économique du liban mais
également un gouvernement qui inspire
confiance au marché financier avec un
pays donc le classement dans les grands
par les grandes agences de notation fond
comme neige au soleil
donc si le gouvernement prochain et
formait sur les mêmes bases que les
anciens gouvernements et malheureusement
tout porte à croire que hassan diab et
le président de la république michel
armes sont en train de former le
gouvernement avec cette mentalité qui
nous a conduit à la crise
malheureusement ce prochain gouvernement
ne pourra en aucun cas faire face aux
problèmes et apporter des solutions que
les libanais attentes merci beaucoup et
mana je rappelle que vous êtes à
directeur exécutif de la fondation samir
kassir